the World of Tanks development team
continued improving our project
throughout 2013 these improvements
touched on many different aspects of the
game now it's time to shed some light on
the details of the progress we're making
in this video we will tell you about how
the game physics is about to change
Sigmund Freud the founding father of
psychoanalysis considered the passion
for Destruction
a normal feature of the human psyche we
also understand this passion that's why
we've decided to bring the in-game
destruction system to a new level we've
been experimenting with this system for
more than a year all destructible
buildings have been remade now buildings
don't simply change from one condition
to another they do it in a beautiful way
wooden houses break into logs frail
Hut's fall into pieces brick walls crack
along the brickwork joints when a
building is destroyed you may see an
entire wall topple at the ground and
smash itself into smaller fragments
these fragments can also interact with
vehicles and be destroyed as well we try
different detail levels of destruction
of brick buildings big fragments small
fragments a combination of big and small
fragments we even created a model of a
building that literally breaks apart
into single bricks the way a building
can be destroyed depends not only on the
type of material it is built up but also
on the type of shell that hits it an
armor-piercing shell will just pierce a
hole in the wall while the blast of a
high-explosive shell will scatter pieces
in all directions
buildings can be complex
for example two-story you can fire at
the first storey and it will be
destroyed then the second storey will
also collapse some in-game objects
cannot be destroyed due to gameplay
requirements it must exist however they
also have some elements that can be
disrupted you can shoot off a balcony or
break glass all this became possible due
to the introduction of the havok
physic's engine this software is used in
the gaming and film industries to create
special effects of course havoc will not
only be used for the building
destruction system we decided to go
further and provide vehicles with
physically correct behavior now all
elements of Tanks including side panels
from tennis and chains naturally rock
and dangle when vehicles are moving they
can be lost during combat action for
example when tanks collide they can also
be shot off by enemies the most
significant changes will be to vehicle
suspensions now wheels will roll over
uneven terrain in a natural way the t26
was probably the most difficult tank to
remake it has a double suspension that
consists of several suspension arms so
its behavior is quite complex
however we were successful but despite
the move ability and accuracy of the new
suspension something in its behavior
seemed to still be wrong the problem was
the tracks we built a new model to
simulate tracks without using any third
party instruments every single track
element is now calculated and animated
separately work on tracks continues the
next step is to make their behavior
realistic not only in motion but also
when they are knocked off droop off the
wheel unreal and so on with the
introduction of client physics what
players have long wanted will finally
come true World of Tanks will utilize
multiple processor cores havoc will take
full advantage of the computing power of
multi-core processors however players
will be able to turn this feature off on
computers with low performance
characteristics but the game will remain
the same for them because server-side
physics will change as well our work
making vehicles behave more
realistically led to the development of
a new model of Tanks powertrain this
model simulates the work of the whole
mechanism from clutch to wheels even
mechanical losses are taken into account
transmission gears change when a vehicle
is on the move now tanks behave like
real combat vehicles to the last detail
of course players will need some time to
get used to the new behavior of the
vehicles players won't experience any
technical difficulties though such
action is as gear change or smooth
depression of the clutch pedal will be
controlled automatically by your in-game
driver improvement of the physical model
of the powertrain yielded interesting
results now interaction between vehicles
and terrain can be simulated more
accurately the current physics model
provides only one settable parameter
rolling resistance it influences how
fast a vehicle gathers speed and what
it's top speed is accurate simulation of
the powertrain and the new physics
system allows us to consider many more
parameters of terrain besides the
already existing rolling resistance
traction and terrain deformation
parameters will also be considered this
means that vehicles will behave
differently depending on the type of
terrain this difference will show an
acceleration time slipping and side-wise
skidding changes in the way suspension
Springs work will also be included in
the more realistic physics engine in the
new model the stiffness of the springs
depends on degree of compression
this means that Springs are quite smooth
when there's little compression and this
allows driving over small bumps without
rocking but when bouncing over larger
bumps Springs will behave as stiff
suspension Beauty changes in server-side
physics tank turrets can now be blown
off the first challenge was that there
was no separate turret in the
homogeneous collision models of Tanks
then as the turret became a separate
model we experimented with tearing it
away just by applying some momentum it
could fly away by dozens of meters it
looked funny but completely unnatural
so work continued there are many things
to be considered for the turret to
behave realistically when applying
initial impulse in the end we ended up
taking into account the internal volume
of the tank we also consider the volume
of remaining ammunition and even the
type of ammunition when the turret comes
off destruction of its base is uneven
and circumferential it's damaged heavier
at some points and less at others
initial angular velocity or in other
words how the turret will spin in the
air is determined by where the turret
attachment is weaker after the turret
comes off it exists as a material body
with its own mass it can serve as cover
it can fall down and cause damage or
destroy a building or damage a vehicle
it can even destroy a vehicle so beware
of flying turrets the changes we made in
order to implement the tangible turrets
led to changes and another aspect of the
game players will now be able to move
various objects these can include trucks
trolley cars wagons or even an entire
train some cars can be moved as well if
they're big enough the behavior of
trucks is worth mentioning we're rather
proud of this feature trucks in the game
have soft suspensions wheels are
spring-loaded the front axle can turn
so if you somehow move a truck and its
front axle turns and then you push it
from behind the truck will roll in a
curve only if its front axle straightens
out will it move straight some buildings
are still indestructible but this may
change one day we're also experimenting
with server-side realistic destruction
of large objects we already have a
technology that allows buildings to
break into fragments and finally there
is another feature that will affect the
behavior of tanks now they can flip over
we could have implemented this feature
long ago together with falling off the
hills unfortunately the game wasn't
ready for this then for such an advanced
technology so I had to impose a maximum
rotation of 60 degrees so the tanks
couldn't turn over now we're completely
ready for turnovers so all I have to do
is remove this restriction this is all
for now we have told you about the most
important upcoming changes to world of
tanks physics follow the news we got
more surprises for you good luck on the
battlefield